it was you know one of the hardest calls
that I've I've had to make in in the 18
years of running the company
company-wide announcements from Tech
CEOs have all had similarities recently
this is a very difficult decision tough
decision Amazon is preparing to lay off
up to 10 000 workers meta is cutting
eleven thousand
Netflix has made big cuts so has Shopify
snap Twitter
well maybe that's a unique circumstance
here are the macro and micro reasons why
the tech industry is seeing massive
layoffs right now
picture it Silicon Valley 2019 these
three major tech companies revenues were
growing steadily as everything moved
online and their number of employees was
also growing then of course the pandemic
hit
people began shopping from home binge
watching
and just generally being online more not
only did the revenues of many of these
tech companies Skyrocket
but so did their head count
I think Amazon is the quintessential
example here if you're promising two-day
shipping you have to deliver two-day
shipping Amazon in response just had to
hire many many more people not only did
Amazon grow its delivery operation but
it also grew from its web services
companies and businesses that might not
have been online before now had an
online presence you have to host that
data somewhere and so Amazon saw the
cloud computing service do very well
during the panda
revenues stayed High through 2021 and
many Tech CEOs thought the growth would
continue at the same rate they had seen
for the last two years
we're going to continue to invest invest
aggressively into the growth
opportunities that we see so they
continued the hiring spree and not just
a lot of employees but some expensive
employees because this is also when the
talent war is ramped up where companies
provide for in-demand employees Facebook
launching the metaverse is a prime
example from now on we're going to be
metaverse first not Facebook first we
saw about a hundred or so people leave
Microsoft for meta and some of these
people who left the company said that
they were being offered double their
salary but by 2022 consumer habits had
changed in a big way people were no
longer stuck inside Netflix saw a drop
in subscribers for the first time in
over a decade people began spending more
of their money on services and less on
Goods revenues for many tech companies
started to stall or even decline for the
first time some of these CEOs sort of oh
overestimated where that new Middle
Ground
Ed which is why they're explaining while
apologizing that they grew too fast
each tech company has also faced
distinct problems a major one Apple's
privacy change which required apps to
ask users if they wanted to be tracked
it affected a key component of many of
these social media companies digital ad
focused business models add in the
threat from Tick Tock taking away
viewership from other social media
platforms when you have all these things
happening at the same time I think
that's
what really did it for these companies
and put them in the bigger companies
aren't outliers either layoffs have been
happening across the industry throughout
2022 but have recently surged but even
though these are a lot of layoffs the
companies are not shrinking back to
pre-pandemic levels
meta's layoffs will bring the number of
employees to about here
Amazon's to about here Netflix brought
the employee account here to be clear a
lot of these companies are still growing
it's just that the growth is slowing
back to sort of pre-pandemic or early
pandemic levels CEOs also say the timing
has to do with the threat of an economic
downturn
well there certainly have been a lot of
changes very quickly in the
macroeconomic environment we're in a
very rapidly changing economic
environment in some ways these layups
are a bit proactive I mean some of them
have said we're doing this now so that
we never have to do this again these
layoffs while concentrated in the tech
industry are still a lot tens of
thousands of people for a lot of people
this reversal and these layoffs
are something that they've never seen
before
the tech industry had the exceptionally
pronounced experience of growing during
the pandemic and now while the rest of
the labor market is growing they're
having the exceptional experience of not